[Musik]
[Applaus]
ich brauche so ganz genau und sie auf
einmal dass ihr was jetzt noch hinterher
ich willkommene damen und herren
scheinen diese stinkender motorenpalette
umfasst und werden deswegen nicht nur
die kamera mitnehmen werde wieder kaputt
gehen wäre durch die chicken müsste oder
wechselt euro bezahlt werden
sein und wahrscheinlich wird später in
dem video noch ein lokal reagiert komme
so bleibt auf jeden fall dran und wisst
ihr wir heute noch gar nicht guten
morgen gesagt haben nach du kleiner wie
geht's dir wo sie denn seine augen alter
denn sieht man dich total schlecht bei
tageslicht aber jetzt gerade ist der
glaube ich orange orange muss ein
bäuerchen machen unterbreitet das ipad 3
ein mittagsschlaf machen
ich kenne das ja schön mein kleiner drei
ich würde das hat sich wieder voll
falsch angehört habe selber gesehen wenn
man beides nicht versucht mit dem eis
besprechen dann erkennt man dieses haben
von den fachlich
ok absolute neuheit für mein eindruck
dass es diesmal wirklich klar
[Musik]
wir gehen jetzt zum einstand aus aber
mit drei von gefühl weil ich meine
kamera halt nicht mitnehmen aber es hat
geregnet meine alten forschen einfach
nur noch mehr kaputt hier noch ein paar
freunde kennen noch hier nebenan
deswegen vor dem der sprecher auf den
beiden mal schauen was der morgige tag
mit sich bringen ich werde jetzt auf
jeden fall schön dass meine acht neun
stunden und herren das gut für das
gerade wirklich erst ein riss oder sogar
als letztes geleit
im halb zwölf zu ende da hab ich würde
trotzdem einfach sagen freunde
[Musik]
riether
später wieder
[Musik]
fertig
ich gucke da die tiere alles in trend
folgte neue fastnacht folglich die
glocken läuten liebte schalten nur
unsere videos laufen
vitamine sich dort fragt mich einfach
schon die ganze zeit wo meine socken um
eine unterhose sind die linie an drei
tagen hier in höfer da mittendrin
ich weiß dass ich zu beginn des blogs
gesagt habe wahrscheinlich jetzt später
in dem video noch ein locker reagiert
kommt gerade eine wendung der ereignisse
frage ob ich bock haben mit ihm einen
seite bleiben wieder aufzunehmen
machen wir unbedingt bis zum ende des
block konstant freunde bei einem ende
der sicher wieder ein paar kommentare
beantworten und da geht wohl um den
namen für mein haustier
ein teil
[Applaus]
beispiele etwa 100 fifa und der
verlierer da ein bild bei den jeweils
anderen davon eine stunde heraus offen
bleiben
weitere 1 luca meine damen und herren
das motto ist jetzt online marktplatz
will die post wird kkw probe stellen wir
haben in dem informationen mit den
fahrern gehörte mit den rängen findet am
die mittel dazu ein video aufgenommen
man kommt nicht über den punkt auf jeden
fall so ein schild aus der umgegend
gehöre ich hin steigen
hierunter herrscht ich bin
da willst du einmal hinter ramsauer für
meinen blog eben laser luca ok alles
klar dank wird abonniere ich habe ein
video bei facebook gesehen war einfach
so so viele hühner einfach umfliegen
wts aber das bringt es jetzt auch schon
zu der heute ne die wurde dokumentiert
wer wohl alle zu helfen könnt ihr euch
noch an die zähne aus dem letzten block
erinnern öffnet aber gut und richtig und
es eine schöne schlacht unter dem video
am erfolg viele in die kommentare
geschrieben und wegen der vorgaben
ersten also schreibt man die kommentare
wenn ihre netto und kannst du mal wieder
einen link mit aufnimmt
locker geht es um die max heftiger
format hoch laden die sache allerdings
nicht auf youtube hochladen kann befinde
mich nicht dabei filmen katastrophe
werden kann weil ich da nicht die rechte
an liedern aber vielleicht demnächst war
luca denkt er hatte hatte er auch aber
nur ein und aus gladbeck bei definitives
freunde und bleibt auf jeden fall noch
dran weil sie bestimmen auch gleich
einen namen
das allerdings dürfte namen für dieses
stimmen richtig gerne geguckt da habe
ich nicht mehr gerne kopiert warst du
den cs und jetzt will ich wählen aus
einem ei schlüpfte und war das eisen
peene zeiten werden kann ich mich
normalerweise eher weniger wir kommen zu
bringen ist allerdings auch ganz schön
gut gelebt wird uns in diesem blog bei
den kern mit nutzbar wird
ich habe dieses und wird hoffentlich
bald schlüpften auf jeden fall 30 nadeln
in die kommentare geschrieben und ich
habe die fünf am häufigsten gleichen
kommentaren mit namen drauf würden ihre
jetzt über eine absolut funktion
bestimmen wie die heißen sollte der
erste name gary der zweiten liga
die irgendwo ein gebraucht
handy oder anderen moment denn durch die
stadt läuft auf einmal einfach vom
kuchen bürger sprechen dass gerade
passiert ist er und seine familie die
kenntnisse und kuchen gestritten und
einer etwas einmal die bürger bleiben
und hier werden die geilen funktion
ich probiere es dabei für reiten das ist
wieder so ein bisschen ein minimum und
jetzt schon wenn ich da haben wir es auf
dem boden
endlich darf sie laden aufmachen und
weil also freuen sind leider schief
gegangen gemacht wtf freude da wenn man
einfach nur ins kino gehen und alles ist
volle polizei unser film geht um 22.40
los ist gerade genau 254 ob jetzt gerade
unsere bürger haben gerade mache und wie
die hier getroffen
der blogger der welt das natürlich nicht
gefällt mir auch nach ungarn in den
himmel
der film ist vorbei die belichtung
scheiße die lupe wie man heute noch gar
nicht trainieren
[Applaus]
die halbinsel jandia folgen laser luca
ok wird immer lukas schon mal die neuen
blitzer gesehen
verlassen und das ist einfach gerade
überhaupt nicht mehr los ich würde sagen
spreche ich einfach wenn ich zu hause
bin weil dann ist das licht auch
deutlich besser ich bin hier fanden den
film eigentlich ganz cool
wir haben doch vorher noch keinen teil
planet der affen gekoppelt nicht darüber
will ich ja vorher doch hinein
vorher noch keinen einzigen tag gedruckt
ist warum nicht gewollt verlauf der für
jetzt besser weil die vorherigen teile
oder schlechter keine ahnung was ich
fanden auf jeden fall ganz unterhalb der
stelle würde ich es allerdings auch den
job beenden eigentlich wollte ich jetzt
noch ein bisschen mit dem einlagern das
hört sich wieder komplett falsch an ich
wollte mal wissen was mit diesen
haustier machen und gucken ob das jetzt
mal endlich schlüpft oder so aber ich
bin einfach hundemüde 3 uhr oder so
ähnlich der block ihr gefallen hat würde
ich mich wer über einen like von euch
freuen wenn ihr die nächste episode luca
kommentiert kommentare kommen wollt dann
schreibt einfach einen kommentar unter
stellten fragen was bedeutet keine
ahnung was würde ich mich auch freunden
in einen kanal abonnieren würdet und
benny schon abonnenten könnt ihr auf die
glocke hier klicken
damit kommt ihr benachrichtigungen und
doppel cool und würde ich nicht an der
stadt auch von euch verabschieden ich
wünsche euch noch einen schönen tag und
gesehen und übermorgen während einem
nächsten block wieder
[Musik]